welcome everyone um I am Priam natarajan
I'm um an astrophysicist and the current
director of the Frankie program in
science in the humanities at Yale uh
which is our Flagship interdisciplinary
program so I'm delighted to see you all
um in the audience today gathered for a
wonderful event this evening we have a
treat in store uh a book talk by one of
of our very own distinguished faculty
members
Carlos okay on to this evening's uh
event Carlos a the is the lison rigs
professor of history and religious
studies and he received his PhD from
Yale in
1979 and he specializes in the social
intellectual religious and cultural
history of the late medieval and early
modern Europe with a focus on both the
Protestant and Catholic reformations the
history of uh the supernatural which is
of course what really fascinated both Dr
Camp who as you all know without whom
this event would not have happened we
are both fan girls uh of his work on the
history of the Supernatural and um and
the history of death before joining the
yel faculty in 1996 he taught at St
John's University uh in Minnesota
University of Virginia and was a member
of The Institute for advanced study at
Princeton for 2 years he's the author of
multiple books um including the war
against the idols uh the Reformation of
worship from arasmus to Calvin from
Madrid to Purgatory uh the art and craft
of dying in 16th century Spain a very
brief history of Eternity which I love
the title I have not read that book
should get that one reformations the
early modern world the life of St teres
of Aila biography and they flew a
history of the
impossible which is what we are going to
be hearing about today the subject of
today's talk he is also the co-author of
Jews Christians Muslims and introduction
to monotheistic
religions and has also ventured into
later time span in history to the 20th
century and the Cuban Revolution in the
Memoir waiting for snow in Havana
which was published in 2003 and it won
the national book award in for
non-fiction in the United States and has
been translated into more than a dozen
languages his second Memoir learning to
die in Miami explores the Exile
experience of being in this country a
past president of the society for
reformation research he is currently
working on several topics in the history
of the supernatural his book
reformations also won many prizes
including the RR Hawkins prize for the
best book of the Year from the American
Publishers Association and the award for
the best book in the humanities in
2017 was also awarded the yaroslav
Pelican prize by Yale University press
so interestingly all of his books are
banned in Cuba and you know what that
means you are immediately a celebrity
once you have a Bann book it's almost
better than having a stalker which is
supposed to be like the first Mark of
you know having arrived at celebrity D
where he has been proclaimed an enemy of
the state that actually sounds scarier
than just having your books band a
distinction that he regards as the
highest of all his honors so hopefully
in the Q&A we can ask him a little bit
more about that so I just want to give
you a brief um notice of upcoming
exciting events we are hosting a
conference on the nature of inference
for those of you who've been attending
the understanding the nature of
inference series series our conference
is on the 14th and 15th of December at
the Greenberg Conference Center at Yale
and if you would like to attend please
go to the website and register and in
Spring 2024 we have a ton of exciting
events preview of Coming Attractions we
have um Dr Meredith brousard who's
investigating the ways in which big data
and Technology are reinforcing race and
gender inequality in our society uh will
be giving us a talk we have a screening
of Richland a new documentary on a small
Town struggling with its identity as a
center of weapon grade plutonium
production and then we have Christian
Cooper on April 4th he was the victim of
the Central Park bird watching incident
for those of you who may um remember so
we have a lot of events coming up in the
spring and now I want to without further
Ado invite Carlos to come and speak to
us thank you so much for accepting our
invitation
well thank you and thanks to everyone
responsible for making this happen and
thank you all for being here on a
cold uh it's almost December
afternoon
um is a history of the impossible
possible is the sub history The
Impossible is the subtitle of my
book for a reason and uh this lecture
will focus on this issue of how
any objective
historian can write a history of things
that almost everyone if not everyone
thinks cannot happen and have not ever
happened
so moving on how can one write a history
of the
impossible I chose two impossible
Miracles that most people would agree
are not only
impossible but as an audience member has
already uh suggested to
me you're not doing the history of the
impossible you're doing the history of
the
ridiculous or as a review that appeared
uh at in The Spectator UK website
last week uh accused me of sliding into
silliness I chose two impossible
Miracles
levitation and
bilocation oh scary
stuff for all Scholars historians or
non-historians Al
like um there can be a war between the
facts first fact before I get into um
trch and and
James there is no denying the fact that
we have testimonies of levitating and
bilocating human beings that is a fact
and it's a fact that can't be denied we
have
testimonies but what kind of fact can
one deal with uh when one deals with the
impossible well er trch um social
scientist came up with a very useful
concept many many many years ago the
social
fact what is a social
fact Let Me Explain before I get to the
Fine points social
fact is an idea or concept or a set of
beliefs
that are widely held and perhaps so
widely held and perhaps even defended or
demanded uh demands certain kinds of
behavior that um one cannot simply go
against them we all live with social
facts uh and for instance in our own day
and age it is a social fact that some
words have become foten there are
certain words you cannot say in public
uh unless like being pillared that's a
social fact and we live with
it levitation and bilocation also social
facts throughout history and in some
parts of the
world and as I used to when I used to
consult with my colleagues who do Asian
religions and I told them what my
project was they were not at least bit
impressed levitation bilocation so what
yeah of course of course you know it's a
social fact in much of older Asian
religion social
fact but there are anomalous events
let's call them
Miracles which cannot ever be ascribed
to Supernatural causes that's our social
fact that we live with these anomalous
events cannot or should not be ascribed
to Supernatural
causes and it is a social fact accepted
very widely accept that humans cannot
defy gravity without
technology and also that humans cannot
be present in two places
simultaneously these are social facts
widely accepted in our own day and
age but then there are also wild facts
uh one of my favorite terms from William
James brother of Henry
James what is a wild
fact it's an anomalous event that just
doesn't
fit any pigeon hole it's actually like
the proverbial square peg that cannot go
into the round
hole some anomalous events let's call
them wild facts defy
explanation
and these are our wild facts when it
comes to the two Miracles I've
examined we have thousands of reports of
humans hover Ing and
flying and we have thousands of reports
of humans being in two places
simultaneously but before I go any
further the accepted way of approaching
any of these wild facts for a historian
is to place brackets
around the phenomenon
itself the event can be
studied the testimonies can be studied
but but the proper thing to do is to
take either a functionalist or
structuralist approach to the event and
analyze what meaning and
purpose belief in this event has for the
people who are testifying that they
witnessed it so you have to bring your
brackets to the
phenomenon I am trying
to question the
brackets
or their
necessity but down to Brown uh brass tax
what is a
miracle in the Christian tradition which
is the only tradition I'm focusing on in
my
book St Augustine of Hippo was uh
challenged by a manikan named
Fus who argued that Christian Miracles
were contrary to Nature and therefore
false
impossible Augustine replied by saying
that there is and I quote there is no
impropriety in saying that God does
something against nature when it is
contrary to what we know of
nature for we give the name nature to
the usual and known course of Nature and
whatever God does contrary to this we
call prodigies or Miracles so the focus
is on whatever knowledge one has of
nature not what the laws of nature
accepted in one's day and time might
be aquinus uh in the 13th
century had this definition of miracle
in the Suma contenus a miracle is a
sensible effect produced by God which
transcends all the forces of
nature with emphasis on
transcends
and um a
miracle aquinus argued does not
contradict destroy antagonize or violate
forces of nature it is an effect which
exceeds all the inherent powers of the
forces of nature it is something that
happens as an exception to the regular
working of the established order and
God who made the forces of nature can
cause something to happen at his will
which gives evidence of his dominion
over these
forces but Along Comes the Protestant
Reformation in
1517 uh can be dated exactly to October
31st
1517 uh here's Martin Luther on
Miracles those visible works are simply
signs for the ignorant unbelieving crowd
and for their sakes that are yet to be
attracted but as for us who know already
all we do know and believe the gospel
what do we want them
for main point Luther and all the other
major first and second generation
Protestant
reformers rejected the existence of any
Miracles post the year 100 I'll get to
that in a couple of minutes why this
they thought this was
so
second generation reformer John Calvin
on
Miracles and this is key we may also
fitly remember that Satan has his
miracles which though they are deceitful
tricks rather than true powers are such
a sort as to mislead the
simple-minded and untutored look at that
condescension idolatry has been
nourished by wonderful Miracles yet
these are not sufficient to sanction the
superp ition either of magicians or
idolators harsh words
Calvin of
course Protestant Reformation was all
about returning to the Bible the Bible
alone so what about all those miracles
in the Bible and you know the Hebrew
Bible the Old Testament is full of
Miracles my God crossing the Red
Sea and many many many others uh and the
New Testament is is full of Miracles
too uh is
a Christ healing the blind man
Renaissance period
painting but uh it's not just the
gospels that are full of Miracles The
Acts of the Apostles also relates that
the apostles themselves after Jesus's
resurrection and Ascension performed all
sorts of Miracles and not just healing
Miracles but wondrous Miracles such as
St Paul being bitten by a venomous snake
snake and and surviving totally
unharmed what to do what to
do there are miracles in the Bible why
can't there be any Miracles
now but before I go any further with
slides there is this very
significant tactical pical issue that
all the first and second generation
Protestant reformers had to face
their Catholic opponents were constantly
asking where are your
Miracles right we have a long history of
Miracles and we have all these Miracles
where are your Miracles your church must
be false so
solution Miracle stopped at the year
100 it's it's known in Protestant
theology as the cessation of
Miracles uh
argument that um this doctrine affirms
that the Miracles described in the Bible
ceased at the end of the apostolic age
around the year
100 and why 100 well that was the
accepted date more or less for the death
of the last of the twel Apostles the
Apostle
John Jesus had commissioned the apostles
because in the Gospels there is
blatantly stated that he gives them
power to do all these miraculous
things but there's nothing else in the
New Testament that says that this
was had a a expiration code stamped on
it the argument ran like this for the
cessation of
Miracles miracles were necessary to
convince people that Jesus was indeed
the Son of
God once the first and second and
perhaps even third generation of
converts were won over to belief in
Jesus as the Messiah and the Son of
God Miracles were no longer
necessary because the greatest Miracle
of all about Christianity was the fact
that more people kept converting without
Miracles that was the greatest Miracle
of
all and um here's a book from 1917 by uh
Benjamin
Warfield counterfeit Miracles uh which
was all about the cation of Miracles
argument because in later protestantism
the cessation of Miracles Doctrine uh
came under attack now Warfield here is
defending still in 1917 the cessation of
Miracles AR argument and there's a long
text from John
Calvin I won't read all of it but this
is the important passage the gift of
healing was temporary all are
constrained to affirm and events clearly
prove then he goes on to say anyone the
rest of the statement basically says
that anyone who is claiming a miracle
past the apostolic age is aping
that's the verb aping the apostles and
simply fooling
people then came the
enlightenment following upon the
Protestant
Reformation and for some reason try this
Google the name of any uh Enlightenment
philosopher and sunglasses and you're
likely to get an image like
this well it is
impossible that a being infinitely wise
can have made laws to violate them he
could not derange the machine but with a
view of making it work better but it is
evident that God all wise and omnipotent
originally made this immense machine the
universe as good and perfect as he was
able if he saw that some imperfections
would arise from the nature of matter he
provided for that in the beginning and
accordingly he will never change
anything in it how rational very
rational and also an echo of Fus the
manquin everyone's favorite David
Hume Dialogue on
Miracles Miracle is a violation of the
laws of nature o f this the manin
again the plain consequence is and it is
a general Maxim worthy of our attention
that no testimony is sufficient to
establish a miracle I'll pause there we
have all these testimonies right that's
the fact we have we have testimonies but
he says no testimony is sufficient to
establish a miracle unless the testimony
be of such a kind that its falsehood
would be more miraculous than the fact
which it Endeavors to establish classic
Hume a miracle
supported by any human testimony is more
properly a subject of Deon than of
argument hence how does one do in a
posthuman world a history of the
impossible Catholic Church tried to um
align
itself against the cessation of Miracles
Doctrine and against all Protestant
arguments against Cath Catholic
Miracles remember that line from Calvin
Satan too has his
miracles part of the Protestant argument
was that
any post Apostolic age Miracle claimed
by the Catholic Church could only be a
demonic trick rather than a miracle yes
Satan has his miracles we'll return to
this curious asymmetry I call it between
Catholic and Protestant thinking on
miraculous but this man Prospero
lambertini an enlightened
Pope who became Pope Benedict the 14th
and look at his dates 1740 to
1758 he served by the way uh as
The Devil's Advocate in Rome for several
years that's the the person charged in
canonization cases
with calling into doubt everything
that's being presented about the saint
so he knew exactly what was going on
there's a wonderful book U
titled the rationalization of Miracle uh
by Pao perigi if you're interested in
this subject he details uh how it was
that in the 17th century the Catholic
Church uh adopted a more quote unquote
scientific approach
to all these testimonies about Saints
and their miracles and actually it was
uh Pope Benedict the
14th who uh more than anyone else
stressed that in the canonization
process What mattered most was heroic
virtue rather than Miracle working and
it still to this day Remains the primary
objective in Catholic
canonization process even though you
still need Miracles they're of a
secondary nature and he wrote this
massive
um s it's a multivolume
book on the beatification of the
Servants of God and the canonization of
the blessing which uh when I first uh
saw the title I said oh I must run and
read this book
until I realized how humongous it was
and that by the way this is still pretty
much in
use some tweaking has been done but this
is still the guide book to this
day
but okay uh re uh Protestant
Reformation
Enlightenment then comes the secular
age and Along Comes uh the invention of
social science and this man in
particular is very scary looking man Max
babber
argued that the key turning point in
Western
history had
been this Protestant cessation of
Miracles doctrine that is what made the
world
modern key point was in English
translation the disenchantment of the
world in German it's much clearer and
zelt the de magic
deification of the world because the
German word zba is
magic so along with the Protestant
reformers who assigned all miracles to
Satan now vber is pairing up and
Protestant reformers did this too
paired Catholic
rituals and
miracles with
magic which Christians have never
thought is as something good so what
kind of urong is there from the
Protestant reformers well there are no
more sacramental miracles like the the
Eucharist The Bread and Wine turning
into the actual
physical flesh and blood of Christ
although Luther continued to believe in
the real presence he did not
believe that it could be explained and
it definitely was not the body and
blood under some other guys other
Protestant reformers went further
denying the real
presence all the Miracles in the lives
of the Saints such as this one uh
depicted here by Diego Velasquez the
temptation of St Thomas Where Angels
came to rescue him from a prostitute his
family had placed in his room so that he
would change his mind and not join the
Dominican
order and if Co does return you can get
this very
nice
uh
mask which also you know if you believe
in miracles will you know
repel the co
virus
and uh Miracles within mystical Visions
forget about them human beings do
not do not cross the boundary into the
Supernatural and cannot that was part of
the Anon
or disenchantment of the world and uh
human beings don't have visions of
people and Heaven like the Virgin Mary
or
Jesus no simply does not happen mystical
ecstasy
no and the physical phenomena or
physical Miracles that accompany
mystical ecstasy such as the
Stigmata
no if something like this
happens for Protestant theologians it's
demonic for
enlightened
humans it's a trick it's probably
self-inflicted so here's the tough one
levitation and one reason I picked
levitation is because not only that it's
so scandalously
impossible but also that the individuals
that I focus on in the 16th and 17th
century the testimonies of their
levitations are such that if one accepts
the testimonies at face value
the levitation could not have been a
trick perform with wires or ropes or any
other such
Contraptions but I'll pause before I
Forge
ahead levitation was faked all the
time and especially in the 16th and 17th
century and we have lots of records of
how these fraudsters are then processed
caught and in many ways punished and
there's a whole section of my book that
focuses on the
frauds as pretty much a control in a
scientific
experiment all right you've got
someone who levitations are
accepted by the Catholic
church for every person whose
levitations are accepted you've got
several whose levitations have been
rejected as fraud fraudulent so there is
this back the Prospero
lambertini and the method of
rationalizing the miraculous and
approaching
Miracles
empirically levitation is not found in
the New
Testament except for perhaps this
cryptic uh passage from St Paul in
Corinthians second Corinthians quote
Know a Man in Christ who 14 years ago
was caught up to the third heaven
whether in the body or out of the body I
don't know God knows it's it's the only
kind
of Passage that comes close to hinting
at
levitation but there are some U
magicians non-Christian magicians 1 2
third fourth fifth sixth Century who uh
are going around uh
levitating um such as Simon megus
um but Christian Saints levitating you
don't find them in the early
church you begin to see them uh in the
later Middle Ages and the first
depiction of a levitating Saint uh that
anyone knows has been uh painted is this
one by
gioto of the Ecstasy of St Francis
and in the Life of Francis by
Bonaventure here's the text that goes
with this this image there he was beheld
praying By Night his hands stretched out
after the manner of a cross his whole
body uplifted from the earth and wrapped
in a shining
Cloud as though the wondrous
illumination of the body were a witness
unto the wondrous Enlightenment of his
mind so he's not only levitating he's
glowing let's skip ahead there are
numerous levitating Saints in the later
Middle Ages as a matter of fact with
each passing Century the numbers of
levitating Saints gets higher and
higher and we get to the 16th
century it's a response to the cath to
the Protestant Reformation okay you guys
don't have Miracles we
do and the number of levitating Saints
increases in the 16th century in 17th
century but part of this increase has a
lot to do with the invention of the
printing press and the publication of
geographies or lives of the Saints this
is one reason it's much easier to find
levitating
Saints in the early modern period than
even the later centuries of the Middle
Ages is that you've got hagiographies
that are printed and distributed
widely and here we have uh the founder
of the Jesuit order St ignatious Lola
who was um
observed levitating and
glowing he was observed many times at
night his room filled with a bright
light he's seen raised up in the air
with his knees bent weeping sighing and
saying my God how infinitely good you
are and uh
the Jesuit hagiographers liked this
scene very much these three images are
from graphic geographies a genre of
geography that became very popular in
from the mid 16 Century into the 17th
century where you know you pick up the
life of the saint and it's basically
like a comic
book and the text is in it I left the
text here so you could see how little
text there is accompanying
the image so image after image after
image and notice also in these
depictions there is always a
witness the testimony is linked to the
image St Teresa of Aila uh also
levitating and
glowing and um this happened in front of
the bishop of Avila and a crowd of
witnesses I'll pause for a second and
add something about St Teresa that's not
in the
slides St Teresa hated to levitate and
tried to resist
it and begged her nuns I actually
ordered them because she was her
Superior if you see me going up hold me
down if I do go up pull me down and she
would hold on to any object that she
could as she felt coming on and tried to
stay grounded
unsuccessfully including one time in the
kitchen while she was frying eggs with
the last few drops precious drops of
olive oil that her Convent had left and
she goes up with a frying pan in her
hand but the nuns are under obedience so
they trying to pull her down but they're
worried that precious oil is going to
spill but they cannot pull her down I'll
add this too this is very common of
early modern as well as medieval
levitations when does it
happen it happens during mystical
ecstasy it is a byproduct of mystical
ecstasy and it is not something that is
willed it is against your
will but more than
that you see it here you see it in these
two and other images
in mystical ecstasy certain kinds of
mystical ecstasy the body goes into a
cataleptic seizure and that's a medical
term becomes
rigid the senses cease to
work whatever position you're in when
you enter mystical ecstasy you're
Frozen
and it's kind of humorous but also very
sad many of these levitating Saints
their
communities prick them with
needles Place candle lit candles right
in front of their
eyes or my
favorite blow on them because they're so
nearly weightless blow on them to watch
their body waft across the
room while they are in this cataleptic
state so so Teresa
resisted and we don't have time for it
but she is
the not the only one but the one
levitator who has devoted the most page
space in her writings to describing what
it feels like to levitate and what it
feels like to resist these
levitations and there she is uh
levitating joint with St John of the
Cross uh one Trinity Sunday in either
1573 or 74 nobody has fixed the date but
they were discussing the Trinity uh and
all of a
sudden they both go
up and
uh here's another depiction of
this I began this
project 40 years ago in June of 1983
when visiting the convent of the
Incarnation in
Aila tour guide is taking us
around uh here's the kitchen where where
Teresa cooked with her pots and pans uh
here's the refectory where the nuns
ate and one of my favorites here's the
staircase where the devil pushed uh
Teresa down the stairs and she broke her
arm and then we get to this spot the
locoro where the nuns spoke with the
outside
world and here's the spot where Teresa
and John of the Cross levitated together
for the very first
time my head
exploded it was a cognitive
uh experience like I have never had
before there's nothing emotional about
it it's purely rational Kant would have
been very proud of me uh here's it's a
fact that to to the people in this place
this is a fact and from here on in on
and off on and off over 40 years until
covid
hit and then uh this book was written
mostly during
covid and um by
then a
miracle the older a text was printed
text the older it was more likely it was
I would find it
online and every geography I needed
every every single one except two or
three was online for me so I I didn't
need to leave the house and from the
bowels of Yale library system if I
requested a book it would be neatly
wrapped in brown paper and mailed to my
doorstep another
miracle so greatest levitator of all
time St Joseph of copertino
1663 I mean 16003 to 1663 and you have
here are three different depictions of
the same
levitation he looks more like
Superman than than any other character
you might be familiar with what's so
special about St
Joseph and look at the time period
16003 1663 Protestant Reformation has
already triumphed taking over great
chunks of
Europe uh so this is a century
after Luther and Calvin but um from very
early age he was very Pious he would go
into mystical ecstasies and
levitate but he also happened to
be mentally
challenged and his his name his nickname
given to him by locals was
bapa open mouth
so uh The Village Idiot
basically who was rejected twice by uh
first by the franciscans and secondly
the Capuchin because he couldn't do
anything right except
levitate which hindered his
work long story short he ends up
becoming member of The Franciscan order
and being ordained a priest
um his ordination was meant to be a
humiliation to his Superior who was
treating him like pardon the expression
a oh so you're treating this man
this way I'll teach you some humility
you prepare him to be a priest and you
make sure he gets
ordained he managed to pass the test
because the only question asked of him
was on the only passage out of the
entire Bible that he knew by
memory which is why he is the patron
saint of test
takers processed by the
Inquisition he
passes why would the Inquisition
processes him well this could be demonic
you know same thing with St Teresa same
thing with all these other early modern
levitators they had to clear away the
suspicion that this might the devil at
work and what was the best way the clear
way the
suspicion
humility humility these people are not
trying to attract attention to
themselves they're always humble in
their dealings with
others
Joseph not only levitated he flew and he
flew forwards and backwards sometimes
upside down
and here's an image of him uh uh upon
seeing the Shrine of the Holy House of
Loretto he goes
up and uh many descriptions of him going
up as high as trees Treetops one
time uh he goes up to a treetop
levitating and then comes out of his
ecstasy in the treetop and they have to
get a very tall ladder to help him
down and uh the this painter is unknown
um
this just sold at auction last year no
no price disclosed no owner disclosed
I'd like to know who has this hanging in
their
palace Joseph had triggers what
triggered his ecstasies all sorts of
things religious imagery
especially hence you know his flying to
that
cross sacred places seeing the
Shrine of the Holy House of
Loretto and the image to the left is
actually uh St Joseph flying over the
heads of the Spanish Viceroy in Italy
and his wife and their entire Entourage
and his wife fainted and had to be
revived with smelling salts you see
her there passed out right under Joseph
but the reason he flew over their heads
is he had seen the this image of the
Virgin Mary and was just immediately ah
mama that's what he called these images
a
mama other triggers the sacraments
saying Mass most of his levitations
occurred while saying mass and I'll
return to this in a minute or two and
people in need of healing or of
conversion these two paintings blend all
these triggers
on the left you have him uh dragging up
a young man who had lost his mind and
was considered insane he placed his hand
on him to heal him and went up with
him and it's a double Miracle a
levitation and a healing the other image
is St Joseph of Cupertino saying Mass
levitating at mass and the person
astounded is Johan Friedrich the
Lutheran Duke of
Saxony who converted to Catholicism
after seeing Joseph levitate in this
manner and um again I I have some pauses
this is another
pause uh a scientist in the UK in
Wales got an advanced copy of my book an
emailed me he was very
excited by my descriptions of St
Joseph's
levitations and the email said basically
I'm
paraphrasing I am so
happy this proves so much about my
theory of levitations being a break in
time
space and what he likes so much about
Joseph is the fact that you know this
cataleptic uh
posture involv not only his body but his
clothing which retained its folds the
folds would not
change and even when upside down the
Habit would not come flopping down over
his head it would
stay
and when coming out of the cataleptic
seizure especially when saying Mass
Joseph even after 3 hours would pick up
whatever spot in the missile he was at
the next
word so this uh scientist got all
excited because yes he's outside of time
space there's no time oh she was so
excited I I couldn't be as excited
because I couldn't understand the
technical terminology he was throwing at
me he went into ecstasy in solitude as
well as in public and even went over the
head of Pope Urban VII who supposedly
exclaimed if this man dies before I do I
will testify at his canonization inquest
that he flew over my head so talk about
testimonies this is um one of the
highest placed people who testified that
he did in fact defy
gravity so in the Baroque Period 17th
century mostly you you begin to see in
Catholic sacred art more and more
depictions of levitating Saints uh and
especially of medieval levitating Saints
who had not received attention from
medieval
artists so here you have a very very odd
uh rendition of the stigmatization of St
Francis by viente gucho an Italian
artist who hispanicized his name from
kuchi to cucho who um his father is also
an artist who was brought to the Spanish
court and on the right you also have
another cucho uh levitation of St
Anthony of padwa a contemporary of of St
Francis and um a levitation of St
Dominic 13th
century and a another cucho vision of St
Hugo one of the early carthusian monks
karda was a specialist from what as far
as I can tell I'm not an art historian
and every colleague I've ever had in any
art history Department always reminds me
you are not an art
historian but cucho has more paintings
representing levitating Saints than
anyone else I
found so the past the history the
miracle is therefore thrown to the Past
for display either on Monastery or
Convent walls or church walls
and here's one of the most amazing
depictions Baroque depictions of
levitation uh from murrio another
Spanish artist uh there are arguments
still going on as to who this Franciscan
frier is doesn't matter he was in the
kitchen he under his vow of obedience he
was supposed to do kitchen work but he
went into ecstasy and started levitating
and glowing so Angels Came to do his
work work and there on the left you see
the eyewitnesses who come and find him
this painting is huge and it it hangs in
the Lou Museum it was stolen by
Napoleon's Army and never returned so
add this to the list with the Elgen
marbles uh things that need to be
returned the other Miracle is by
location and here's your familiar figure
uh ah here's where we are and and there
there it is you can buy that inflatable
scream figure by the way just Google
it don't tell my wife she's getting that
for a Christmas
present gioto also a bilocation by St
Francis so again throwing things back to
the
past greatest Bator not the greatest cuz
I found one
later but an extreme Bator s Maria
deaga almost the same exact dates as St
Joseph 16002 to
1665 a Franciscan nun who byoc
repeatedly and
um crossed the ocean never left AGA
physically but was seen by the humano
natives in present day New Mexico and
Texas visited them reportedly over 500
times to christianize them it's a tricky
case very tricky but she acquired um
such a reputation as being a genuine
Bator that she is a legend in the
American
southwest and by sheer coincidence one
of my uh teaching fellows last year was
traveling through S San Angelo
Texas sent me a photo s Angelo Texas has
erected a huge
statue of the lady in blue as she was
known in in that area because her habit
had a little bit of blue so she crossed
the ocean back and forth and as if that
were not enough another impossible
miracle I decided to not focus on too
much in the book The Virgin Mary
appeared to her constantly
and dictated her autobiography to this
nun and she wrote it down was ordered to
burn it she burned it another Superior
came in and says where's that life of
Mary oh I I was asked to burn it oh
write it over again it's over a million
words long the mystical city of God is
the English
title and it uh guess which film relied
on it heavily
Mel Gibson's The Passion of the
Christ she describes things that are not
in the New Testament so it's a it's an
even iier sort of impossible
Miracle because her mystical city of
God could be considered a Fifth
Gospel and there in this painting you
see her paired up with none other than
John the
Evangelist who was also for a long time
believed to be the author of the book of
Revelation or the apocalypse with the
New Jerusalem in the
background and there you see the sheer
size of this work of
hers which ended up being condemned by
The Faculty theological faculty of the
sorbon but approved
by no surprise
salanka Alcala louan which was under
Spanish control but inexplicable tulus
they all approved
it here's a fact nobody
disputes the first man to ever
levitate with
help in a hot air balloon Jean f pilat
de Rosier love that name
1783 but then to wrap up there is the
wrong kind of
levitation whiches were believed to
levitate and
fly and uh just read the malus malarum
from the 15th century the Witchcraft uh
Treatise of all witchcraft
treatises tells you how they fly to
their sabbaths
how they you know rub oil on themselves
and fly Protestants continued to believe
just about 100% of Catholic medieval
Catholic
demonology but they rejected the much of
the Theology and all of the Miracles
that's the asymmetry I was referring to
before so
um the peak period for flying Saints
is also the peak period for flying
witches and witch hunts which is why I
say the 16th and 17th century is the
peak period for flying humans before the
invention of hot air balloons and
airplanes levitation was possible for
Protestants the image on the
left flying witches and the devil from
an English
text on the right you see how long this
uh uh idea or belief might have
persisted in Spain here's a painting by
Francisco Goya right on the edge between
the 18th and 19th century a series of
paintings on witchcraft commissioned by
some some Patron I don't know much
about and to show how perverse
historians can be or at least how
perverse I am one of the happiest days
in my research of this book is when I
found a Protestant demonic possession
that involved
levitation in
Boston in
1693 a description of a young teenage
girl who uh could not be held down or
pulled down from the ceiling by several
Burly men and that's how they're
described Burley
who had been brought there by none other
than the great Puritan Minister Cotton
Mather who made them all sign
affidavits
testifying they had been unable to
restrain the girl or pull her
down so there's there's symmetry but
there's asymmetry as far as the
causality of these
levitations
but of
course levitation can be a trick it's
done frequently and there you can learn
how to
levitate but my cases if the
descriptions are in
fact truthful testimony there's no way
those levitations could have been
faked and it comes back in 19th and 20th
Century spiritualism
upper
left a levitation by the great 19
century Spirit spiritualist Daniel
dunglas
Hume which took place in South
Manchester Connecticut in the
1830s and on the right you see um a
Welsh
spiritualist levitating the reason
everyone looks so
uh asleep is that the photo is taken in
infrared light and the man holding the
switch for the camera is none other than
the
levitator
so levitation is absolutely
possible we have uh gadgets you can put
on your desk that levitate we have
electromagnetic trains
one of my sons spent two years in
Japan he levitated for two
years every time he took the
electromagnetic
train and
um
bilocation we do it all the time but of
course the bations and levitations that
I've studied are of a very very
different sort and um
yes I I will be constantly reminded how
ridiculous and how silly the subject is
but to me it's not silly at all and I'm
not saying I can prove that any of these
things
happen what I'm saying is that um
historians need to adjust a little bit
to Supernatural events let's call them
paranormal let's them call them wild
facts
uh those brackets that I was taught to
wield in this very building many years
ago don't you ever consider the
supernatural real you
can't those brackets need um shrinking
let's say and as I argue in my book if
if you want to be uh truly skeptical as
any good scientist should
be uh I I could boast of being cartisian
following decart
the Omnibus EST
duum everything ought to be doubted
including dogmatic
materialism and
um I'll be I'm eager to hear your
questions and
[Applause]
comments thank you so much you want both
yeah I think
maybe us
okay okay questions thank you so much
that was
fascinating uh just as a comment I think
a lot of controversy that you faced
could be prevented by changing the
subtitle of your book uh it could be
what do we call
impossible because this are the cruxs of
the matter I like I I bought my son a
book at some point uh by Noble laurett
and the title was impossible takes
longer and any field I'm an experimental
biologist in any field are the small
miracles where half of the field says no
all all of them say no it's impossible
you know the fire person you know he
goes and hiding and then 25 years later
or 50 years later he gets a Nobel Prize
because uh what was impossible is
possible the same thing if you gave this
lecture 200 years ago saying that you
can talk to you know I can talk to my
son and friend it could be so the key is
I think you somebody s Austin or aquinus
you you quote it it's impossible is we
call impossible what is unexplainable to
us at this stage of that's right what we
know because everything else then
becomes uh like literature yeah no I I
agree with you 100% but I I have my
tongue firmly planted in my cheek by I'm
trying to rile up
people by calling it a history of the
impossible precisely because of what
what you just say that you know there
are many things that one were once
thought impossible that that
aren't and actually I thought I was
doing something novel but I have found
several other books with The Impossible
in the title used in a similar way
including this book by um historian of
religion at Rice University Jeffrey
k r i p p l authors of the
impossible which is about 19th and 20th
Century writers from all kinds of
Specialties who write about impossible
things but yeah I I agree with you it's
Carlos yeah hi I'm Roberto
Gonzalez professor of of literature here
Yale now retired but I'm here also as a
member of the Yale Aviation
Club because I'm a
pilot as
is here who's also a member of the Y
Aviation club we laugh because isn't
there something humorous in this
business business of flying
nuns yes yeah oh certainly there is and
you know most of the flying nuns
um end up being processed by the
Inquisition and discovered to be
frauds so the the the issue is you know
what why are some uh deemed legitimate
and some not legitimate why are there
tricks discovered and why are other
people's tricks not discovered we
actually had a very interesting
discussion in my one of my classes
yesterday it's of course history of the
Supernatural and we were dealing with
19th century spiritualists you know
seances and so on mesmerism right and
mesmerism and theosophy anyway the the
image you saw of Daniel dunglas
Hume he is the one spiritualist medium
that no scient
could
crack discover or prove that he had some
trickery involved in his things so
that's what that's what that's what
keeps me
flying but you know St Joseph is your
patron saint or anyone who
flies it's the patron saint of all
Flyers ironically uh a a job given to
him by uh American bomber pilots who
were bombing the hell out of Italy
during the second world war who proposed
hey here's a good patron saint for all
Flyers if I may follow up on the earlier
question um you know it is true that all
knowledge is provisional and that what
we know even in science is best to date
and is apt to get refined changed
altered but do you think that when these
visualizations and these claims were
made people were not really looking for
an explanation although I noticed that
you noted that anytime you had someone
levitating there was a witness there was
another person in the frame who could
testify that this right so there's sort
of this nod to
evidence but at the same time when you
look at those images at least at the
time they were not meant to be
challenged that's right no they're not
me cause was sought no and as a matter
of fact the Protestants too are looking
for causality there's always a search
for causality but why does cotton ma
insist that these Burly men sign an
affidavit you know say yes I was there
and I tried to hold her down is because
they know they are challenges and I
think that many of those paintings
actually were commissioned because
those commissioning them
knew that this was this was not believed
by 100%
of the people anywhere that there was
skepticism
um and I found not not in regards to
levitation but another miracle
attributed to St Teresa her corpse
refused to
decompose and in one of her he
geographies the he geographer says you
don't want to believe
go ahead don't believe but if you don't
believe this you shouldn't believe any
of the Miracles in the Bible either
which
is uh I don't know if that's a good
argument any other
questions
oh uh if I can add to as again my
background is experimental biology uh it
was absolutely I would call it you know
materialist like in the bad meaning of
this word and then my son sent me an
article from a paper from lanet and
lanet it's a b f you know medical
journal and it described the case of a
person who was you know hit by a truck
or something like this brought in an
emergency room intubated so he was what
they call flatlined right in America
right and then you know after that you
know he was rescued obviously and uh
uh he was in his room and when the nurse
came he oh this is she is she took my
dentures so he could describe that she
took the dentures and put in a certain
draw right while he was flatlined and
the paper presented as one of many cases
and discusses others and as an
experimental biologist I had to take it
as a fact you know from what you say
while fact not I think it should be
distinction between facts which is
something verifiable right and opinions
right somebody can have an opinion that
somebody is flying you know but a fact
is a fact so the thing is and it turns
out there's a department of called
perceptual studies in the University of
Virginia yes that you know uh like uh
follow the work of William James and
multiple things are documented obviously
there's a lot of frosters and everywhere
but science as we know it and accept
also very frous but this is something
that is uh verifiable and unexplainable
that's right it's a modern Miracle you
can call it right but it's
undeniable uh because it's documented
published in last and everything so
maybe this is what I I'm looking forward
to read your book maybe I'm just
repeating what thanks well I'm glad you
brought up this parallel because you
know these um impossible things are on a
spectrum I like like to think and
near-death experiences which is what you
know the subject un category under which
This research
Falls um is part of the spectrum because
there's something undeniable about it
but there's uh V disagreement among um
scientists and medical personnel who
study this phenomenon and I just spent
the past 3 days reading some of this
back and
forth and um I was stunned to discover
that there is a journal of near-death
experiences which was run out of uh
University of Virginia and the center
for what was the title The of
the yeah perceptual studies yeah yeah
and ironically I spent 15 years at the
University of Virginia and didn't know
this Center was
there I had to come here 27 years later
find out oh they were next
door uh but yeah I appreciate what
you're saying very much but I guess the
question is there are many such things
in Neuroscience as well right there are
Phantom arms people feel pain and
Phantom arms and so on and the question
is I'm not sure Miracle is a word I
think mystery might be a better word for
something like that because Miracle is
loaded about near death experiences I
thought well if you're drunk I mean I
didn't experience myself
alcoholics see small green green animals
running around
and people can see many things but if
you can verify what the person and
replicate and replicate verify
replic it and there no way
see you have to stop and say look we
don't know how you work we don't know
how the bra
there there are numerous um
puzzling wild facts of this sort that go
into the 20th
century I you might recall I I refused
to call Maria the greatest Bator of all
time reason for this is that just at the
end of my research it was too late for
me to include this in the book book and
and it was the wrong Century I
discovered that in the 20th century
there was a French nun who bloated more
frequently and even more
outrageously than Maria
deaga and at the very same
time rescued French Resistance Fighters
and downed Allied Pilots by dressing
them as nuns and escorting them out of
the hands of the the
Nazis but most of her
levitations were to
prisons and concentration camps and some
of the testimonies are from individuals
who claim she
came comforted them or in some cases
helped them
escape and um for some odd f i I can't
figure this out because she died in
1951 and there's a lot of French
language literature on
her it's nothing in English nothing in
German nothing in Spanish nothing in any
language other than French uh she's not
known outside of of France um you can
find her on YouTube however but you know
that's always a dicey
proposition uh but yeah there are these
puzzling things I also found a very
somebody uh again emailed me this
something that happened during the 1970s
that I was totally unaware
of uh which was
uh an apparition of the Virgin Mary in
the 1970s of all places a suburb of
KIRO uh
zun which was viewed by over a million
people over a period of two years every
night and was in all the Egyptian
newspapers
of course but never made it to any
newspaper I read in the
1970s uh and most of the viewers were
Muslims not
Christians so these I love these wild
facts that just throw you uh for a loop
and leave you wondering how how it is
that you
know well one way to put it with small
brackets how belief is constructed
or how belief is
reported those two things um have a lot
to do with people's exposure to these
kinds of
phenomena thank you so much for your
presentation it was wonderful um you
talked about how people are reporting
the people who wrote These stories 500
years ago or even our sacred stories had
a whole different vision and
understanding of the cosmos than we do
today yes and yet this is particularly
true of our theologians we still go back
and interpreted them based on their
interpretation of the cosmos they wrote
it from that and we look at it and say
well this is how it was even though they
had this whole different vision of it I
also just wanted to say your story about
Mary Mary is is one of the most revered
women in in Islam she's one of the only
women mentioned in the Quran so it's not
surprising at all that in Egypt it would
be a lot of Muslim women that were were
there it's not you know people sometimes
are shocked by that but it's not a
surprise but but the whole idea of how
do we reimagine our science and our
theology not based on what they wrote
2,000 years and you know not to throw
out the baby with the bath water to use
an old Irish expression to take that
those one that wonderful work but
understand it from how we understand the
cosmos today right and no I agree with
you that that that is a that's a real
challenge however the testimony is not
all from um clerics who are writing
geographies uh the canonization
inquests
are they're almost like legal
proceedings and they they they ask for
testimony from all different sorts of
people I'm I'm sorry all of these all
the oh yes interlocutors right in that
are rooted in faith right and and this
um scholar at Rice University I
mentioned um Jeffrey
he he has argued that
um
belief uh as a social phenomenon as a
social fact has a lot to do with the
occurrence of these impossible
events and impossible phenomena that
there's a correlation between the the
belief and the events although there's
no easy way to explain it
scientifically unless one has discovered
proof of you know interpenetrating
Dimensions which has yet to yet to be
accomplished but uh I think my Welsh
scientist was very very excited by the
suspension of time space something I I
cannot understand and I don't know what
how widely believed he will be in his
own scientific
Community close with
oh some of the narrative details of the
the depictions for instance the crowd is
pretty reverential oh yeah well and I'm
thinking if someone levitated in front
of me if I didn't know them I might be
scared that I was going to levitate too
or that they were going to fall on me um
if it was my friend Nancy I would be
pulling holding on to her so that she
didn't float away but there seems like a
standard in these photo the pictures
that this is how you treat a
levitation that's the depiction
yes the actual accounts are very
different people are frightened half to
death often in the description of the
accounts they're frightened half to
death and
um terror is one of the words
used or you know the equivalent of the
English word
Terror uh the funny thing is that
um I don't know if you know of the uh
Illusionist David Blaine
David Blaine there was a documentary on
David Blaine um years ago like at least
two decades ago where he was performing
tricks on the street in
Manhattan and one of his tricks was
levitation uh which has all to do with
how you place your
feet and the
camera in this documentary was always
aimed at his feet very rarely at his
whole body
but you could see that from certain
perspective it looked like his feet were
off the ground but what I liked is that
the camera also turned to the
audience and at least the clips they
chose for the
documentary everyone is backing away
from
him the body language is constant in all
those clips everybody's
going and then they there's a an
image of a young woman
saying oh he must be very
holy uh so uh yeah if I saw somebody
levitating I think I would uh maybe run
out of the
room uh not just back away
but scary stuff sometimes um I did fail
to mention that every time Joseph of
copertino went
up he let out some sound loud sound
sound and the Italian words are uh greo
shout sto or
Screech and urlo some kind of baso
profundo detonation of sorts which one
time according to several testimonies
made the walls of the monastery shake
and the monks run out of their cells
yelling earthquake
earthquake that's scary
too did it happen well nobody will be
able to prove it we don't have
film but I just received an email
yesterday from some TV
program um that claims they have film of
people
levitating and they want me to
comment and and I said I don't know of
any films of you know people levitating
sure sign me up I want to see
these Carlos uh this wonderful
presentation reminded me of the miracle
of lanciano and other Eucharistic
Miracles so the heart of every Catholic
mass is the consecration as you
mentioned so it's uh suppose you could
term it a quotidian kind of Miracle
right it's of repeated every Mass every
day every hour everywhere in the world
um there are like the miracle valenciano
explicitly um rendered hosts eucharists
right that bleed and are still preserve
thusly you mentioned Luther and how he
believed in the true presence but
subsequent Protestants and obviously
protestantism in general strayed from
that could you walk us through a bit how
we went from Luther believing in the
presence to his contemporaries let's say
and soon thereafter yeah sure it's at
the critical turning point in the
history of the Protestant
Reformation is that Luther continued to
believe in the real
presence but he didn't like the term
transubstantiation or the concept of
transubstantiation because it required
you to be an
Aristotelian and understand what was
meant by substance and accident and also
because there's no description uh of
what happens in Jesus's word so he was
being very biblical about it but he
insisted if Jesus says take this and eat
this is my body right that was the
bottom line for him so in
1529 he and all the other major
reformers of that period meet in one
room at marberg in Germany they have
been brought together by Philip of Hessa
the most powerful Lutheran Prince of the
time so that they can form a military
Alliance among all the different
branches of protestantism
including those Swiss who fight so
well no agree they agree on 13 points
but they cannot agree on 14 the
Eucharist and Luther actually writes on
the table according we
have uh notes that were taken by four
different people so we have four
different transcripts they all say
Luther wrote on the table with
chalk Hulk EST Corpus mayam in Latin
this is my body and then he put a little
cloth over it and every time the Swiss
especially who didn't believe in the
real presence brought up but you know is
could be a metap for Jesus also said I
am the vine you are the
branches
uh he's being metaphorical Luther would
say no no it's not a metaphor no no no
and then he'd lift up the little cloth
and point to the word EST EST EST means
EST it kind of reminded me of of you
know the Bill Clinton affair years ago
what is something the semantics got
involved but Luther finally got just
they started insulting each other at
marberg and Luther at one point says and
you'll have to pardon my
German um look Christ not only said this
is my body he says take this and
eat he says if God had commanded me to
eat
shisa I would have
to so it's the word of God God can do
anything so the Swiss come back at him
and say
look Jesus has a human
body his resurrected body was fully
human and it went up to heaven a human
body cannot be in two places at
once Luther responds you're being too
mathematical God is all powerful God can
be everywhere if he wants to and the
discussion goes on and on and on and on
they can't agree and um no military
Alliance so
um that's that's how it
diverged and in the Anglican Church the
definition of the Eucharist is unclear
enough to suggest
both symbol and Presence at least the
1549 book of common
prayer so there are these
differences
thank you so much once again so let's
all thank caros for thank you thank you
all thank
[Applause]
[Music]
you